si suave est un monoculaire Palacio mr.  Chen
misa-chan satavahanas coliques fictives une
expérience roumaine en Amérique elle notre
oncle Luigi misa-chan voir un médecin près d'un
visa pour le Canada un programme possible est le
plus proche effets sonores sur la technologie de Mille
pour swing Iowa après-midi mr.
Spearman ou le Canada de l'autre côté accorde à
un gros programmeur d'herbes Université un
certain genre Dan no PA
DiPietro Telugu programme venimeux récessif ou
neurologue Miller réalité
les forces de sécurité dans l'univers ont fait
surface avec Gemma G vecteur
Je pense que le programme québécois d'immigration des
investisseurs est une arnaque du début à  terminer
la propagande moi gars si jeune
unité Jamie j'ai vu un homme dire vendre ne vois pas
de Chanel Salalah cherchant clair
cuivreux centralement prédire personnellement la
foire en guerre Matthews mission de ravage en
Amérique elle de Valley rocketry mérite une
garde econ certaine immigration pas
Ahmadi  les québécois donnent toutes les clés d'exp
pour gros disponibles au Québec permettez-moi de
dire à leurs clients de louer un appartement
parce que ça a l'air mieux ils pourraient donner
le bureau de l'avocat dans ma question mais
nous n'avons jamais eu de
merci quand Charlie mon dieu tu
veux divulguer le  minimum possible
ben ouais ok dame rexella
si dose est avérée elle nous présente gaufre
au premier jet feuille à voir sorcier ou être
comme Fairy Avenue acid do ZM say zone
don't get it
la planète le
lieu idéal pour une conférence sur la
migration mondiale et les stratégies de gestion de patrimoine
une industrie où les plus riches du monde
peuvent acheter des visas ou des passeports
de divers pays en échange d'
investissements un marché au potentiel énorme
bien que les industries appelées
migration d'investissement soient la réalité est
que la plupart des  les clients ne se
déplacent pas physiquement mais s'ils en ont besoin, ils le
peuvent et avoir un passeport européen comme
le dit le stéréotype est la
police d'assurance ultime des dizaines de pays,
y compris des îles des Caraïbes et des membres
de l'Union européenne, se font concurrence pour
vendre leur citoyenneté ou leur
statut de résident permanent  en retour d'
investissements au Canada et au Québec ont été
les pionniers de toute l'industrie en
Canada Principe divin
particulier Doraemon Doraemon gas Trump
est fictif,
nous Canada Fidel nous étreignons lorsque vous votez le
cubix attendez jusqu'à ce que sur un poney ou moderne les
éléments supplémentaires dits l'année la plus stupide pour
bien je ne peux pas faire n'est pas un roturier,
nous recevons encore beaucoup de demandes de renseignements sur  c'est
en termes de relocalisation pourquoi les gens le
font éducation soins de santé transport
sécurité et candidat six toutes les cases
mais les programmes de visa d'or comme on les
appelle sont devenus assez controversés
en Europe permis de programme de réalité ou
criminel de fourrage la blonde Sheila
darshan mérite une foire en  la virginité une
fichue fiducie de Portillo ou
un Schengen moins passif
au Canada le gouvernement fédéral a
abandonné son programme d'investisseurs en immigration
en 2014, il n'a pas été jugé
suffisamment avantageux le Québec est devenu la seule
porte d'entrée au Canada via un visa doré dans le
passé, vous savez certainement que nous avons vu des
criminels  et vous savez que des
fugitifs de haut niveau ont utilisé ces stratagèmes pour entrer
dans le candidat, je ne dis pas que
les investisseurs immigrants par un  nd large sont
corrompus mais ce que je dirais, c'est que les
corrompus dans l'ensemble ont tendance à
des schémas de migration millionnaires quels sont
les risques potentiels liés à la
sélection de ces migrants millionnaires
et quels sont les avantages économiques réels
du programme dans le gouvernement du Québec de
tous bords  ont vanté le programme des immigrants
investisseurs depuis sa création en
1986 tafoya gen IV disent que nous nous soucions de l'
argent que j'ai vu tandis que les politiciens le
saluent comme un succès pour le Québec Sakana moi en tant
que programme d'immigration c'est un tout
autre jeu de balle fournit McGann Davis
les pionniers de  l'industrie dit que l'
échec à retenir ces
migrants millionnaires est bien connu osika
narrateur britannique Callaway sauce reconnaissante dans
Oprah's dont le type avocat sympathique
dimanche ne sais pas c'est la poétique
[Musique]
pourtant la création de liens d'affaires
entre le Québec et la Tunisie a été l'un des
objectif principal du programme en face du
véhicule aleejack excusez-nous du soutien sur
la CW
elle savait que Thomas fusillait cette affaire donc à
Kira  Delia forme une division
qu'il s'est soutenue mutuellement sur le
charisme Hong Kong est rapidement devenu leur
centre de recrutement pour ces
migrants millionnaires bien que la plupart d'entre eux n'aient pas
vraiment l'intention de déménager au Québec il
y a une
industrie de l'immigration québécoise lucrative ici pour chaque candidat retenu des
dizaines de milliers  de dollars
en commissions sont partagés par des consultants
avocats et intermédiaires financiers pour
être éligibles les candidats doivent signer une
entente avec un courtier ou une
institution financière reconnue par le gouvernement du Québec
selon une étude de 2011
ces acteurs se sont partagé 1/3 des bénéfices du programme
ce centre-ville de Hong  La tour Kong
est l'endroit où le gouvernement du Québec
exploitait un bureau d'immigration d'affaires
depuis des années, la plupart des candidats au programme
devaient se présenter ici pour une
entrevue de sélection Susanne, il était
sous-ministre adjoint du ministère de l'Immigration du Québec
au
milieu des années 2000 de tous les  bureau à l'étranger, elle a
supervisé celui de Hong Kong lui a donné le
gros  mal de tête gest, surtout lorsque les
candidats ont été refusés,
qu'est-ce que cela dit, nous avons une
politique de dépression totale, la presse ne considère que l'
ampleur de la révision, est-ce Avenue
prison van Kui Tom Lee a dirigé le
bureau de Hong Kong de 2006 à 2009 carton à Ulta
réduire la bande de roulement clé clé  le Soleil de gracia
bhakto SI su leonetti nerf médiatique
opérer un passif dong kyun une bande AHA
confortable dépression pauvre fille en prison
sauf un vecteur de sécurité mu dissimuler
Saed derrière la maîtrise des dollars une balance est une
terrasse en 2005 Jean François Harvey a
plaidé coupable à cinq chefs d'accusation  de faire du
lobbying illégal auprès des
agents d'immigration du Québec pour ses riches clients ne
sait pas si cela a créé un lobbyiste
par conséquent notre communauté en fait Jean
François Harvey a été condamné à une amende de plus de trois
mille dollars pour ces infractions, nous
restons en attente et la procédure de recherche pour
isoler les logiciels malveillants et est  sur l'usine
car Jeremy un surplus
en 2005 le directeur du
bureau d'immigration du Québec à Hong Kong fait face à la
corruption  allégations, il a fait l'
objet d'une enquête interne
qui n'a pas été en mesure d'établir sa culpabilité,
il a été suspendu et a démissionné après
onze mois de mandat à la lumière d'
allégations de corruption contre l'
industrie mondiale des visas d'or, nous sommes allés à
Hong Kong pour voir quels consultants et
les avocats qui recrutent des candidats pour le
programme québécois se sont vraiment épargnés à
huis clos pour les approcher sans
éveiller les soupçons nous avons créé notre propre
immigrant investisseur nous l'avons nommé mr.  Chen
[Applaudissements]
dans la vraie vie mr.  Chen est un chef à Hong
Kong mais pour les besoins de notre mission,
nous l'avons transformé en un multimillionnaire
de Chine continentale PDG d'une
société fictive Jim Bao le léopard d'or nous
lui avons fourni une adresse e-mail un
téléphone portable un assistant et un chauffeur la
finition  toucher une montre suisse dans un
sac à main de luxe pour être éligible au
programme mr.  Chan devra faire un
prêt sans intérêt de 1,2 million de dollars
au gouvernement du Québec pendant cinq ans m.
Chan devra démontrer qu'il a une
fortune d'au moins deux millions de dollars
légalement acquise et il doit également s'engager
par écrit à vouloir s'établir au Québec
mais dans notre scénario m.  Chan dira qu'il
ne veut pas déménager au Québec
préférant envoyer sa fille à l'
université de Toronto ou de Vancouver il
admettra sa richesse car des origines douteuses
disent qu'il possède une usine de sacs en plastique
mais les documents administratifs ont été
détruits par un incendie il divulguera
qu'il est  un usurier et exploite un prêteur
sur gage
alimenté par de l'argent comptant, il reconnaîtra qu'une
partie importante de sa richesse n'a pas
été déclarée aux autorités fiscales chinoises
.
chan en tant que client, ma première réaction
serait désolée, monsieur, mais je ne peux tout simplement pas
représenter que vous
avez une entreprise parallèle qui n'est
divulguée nulle part, il n'y a aucun moyen
de trouver les preuves nécessaires pour
soutenir une demande d'immigration dans
la catégorie des investisseurs Hong Kong  est un
aimant pour les nouveaux riches de
Chine continentale qui viennent ici pour magasiner dans les
nombreux magasins de marques de luxe, beaucoup d'
entre eux achètent également ici pour obtenir des passeports ou
des visas dorés pour d'autres pays, comment
les consultants en immigration et les avocats leur vendent-
ils le programme québécois d'immigration des
investisseurs qui est  ce que nous espérons découvrir
dans notre opération mr.  Chen avec l'aide
de notre millionnaire fictif et de son
équipe alors que nous passons nos premiers appels, les
consultants disent à m.  Chen il peut utiliser le
programme québécois pour s'installer à Vancouver ou à
Toronto mais il doit cacher ses véritables
intentions lors de l'
entrevue de sélection c'est vrai que la loi canadienne
permet aux résidents permanents de se déplacer
librement une fois au Canada mais lorsqu'ils
postulent au programme québécois ils doivent
signer des documents  indiquant leur ferme
intention de s'établir dans la province si
vous ne respectez pas cette intention, il est
possible que la personne fasse l'objet d'
une forme d'admissibilité ou d'une forme
de poursuite en vertu de la Loi sur l'
immigration sous fausse représentation
[Musique]
nous obtenons  un rendez-vous au SEMA et l'
avocat associé Sebastian Jimmy a de
mauvaises nouvelles pour m.  chan gimme lui dit qu'il
n'aura pas à s'installer au Québec mais l'
avertit de ne pas acheter d'immobilier à Vancouver
avant d'avoir obtenu sa
carte de résident permanent c'est seulement risqué quand tu le fais
avant de savoir que PR peut soit te donner
le droit de vivre n'importe où  c'est
pourquoi il est super important d'être
prudent mr.  L'assistant de Chan a demandé s'il
devra acheter une maison à Montréal à
son arrivée même s'il n'y habitera pas
beaucoup de monde ferait-il est de louer un
appartement pour trois mois à Québec
ici et puis vous avez reçu une carte et
ensuite faites  tout ce que vous voulez mais dans le pire des cas,
vous pouvez toujours donner l'adresse de notre bureau
ou quelque chose comme ça mm-hmm-hmm nous
disons à leurs clients de louer un appartement
parce que ça a l'air mieux si vous donnez le
bureau de l'avocat qu'ils pourraient interroger mais
nous n'avons jamais eu de problème et  pour être honnête,
louer un appartement pendant 3 mois en
matériel, ce n'est pas beaucoup d'argent à ce
stade,
ils ont toujours dit à mon patron que tout allait bien,
il propose même d'utiliser n'importe quelle
adresse des avocats de la zone Victor, donc si, pour se
conformer à l'intention de vous démissionner
vous créez vous créez des adresses vous créez de
fausses conditions de vie alors vous ne
remplissez pas l'exigence de l'
intention initiale de résider et vous
participez également à la fabrication de
preuves dans le but de respecter l'
obligation de résidence  e dans un courriel
CBS ng me a répondu qu'il suivait la
loi, il a dit que l'attention de quelqu'un à vivre
au Québec aurait pu changer au moment de son
arrivée au Canada et son conseil de
louer cet appartement qui devait juste
avoir une adresse postale pour recevoir le
permanent  carte de résidence au cas où l'
immigrant devait retourner en Chine
en l'attendant les fonctionnaires du gouvernement du Québec
chargés de sélectionner
ces immigrants investisseurs au
bureau de Hong Kong ont accepté de partager leur
expérience nous cachons leurs identités
et remplaçons leurs voix à cause du
service public  les employés ont besoin de
discrétion
[Musique]
kasumi Elaine Taiana il possédait mon
département nous habitons il y a un temps Québec
le programme oblige les candidats à
divulguer tous leurs biens et à prouver qu'ils
acquièrent leur patrimoine légalement avec
des pièces justificatives des dossiers souvent assez
volumineux Mike Honda ils font voir
ça  la chambre n'est pas pili pili donc le
personnel de la marine a été affecté à sept heures par
candidat la lecture incluse  résumés
réalisation d'interviews et rédaction de
rapports lisman de la vie fournir un salut
sois sans n'était pas un kaki ave de
parte de un laisser un poste propriétaire qui n'a
pas libéré les conteneurs n'a pas
remplacé la boîte de transaction membre yahoo
que c'est pas plus  affaire à notre Purdue
voir ces fonctionnaires qui travaillaient au
bureau de Hong Kong entre 2010 et 2017
disaient que beaucoup de postulants soumettaient
des dossiers douteux
ils le font voir une équipe d'édifice sur Genève a
tiré directement le second post sur LeDoux
elle coton notre gardienne d'un livre
questionnerait  beaucoup de délégation autorise un
appareil photo numérique pour le sortir le Phenom
oblong elle manque définitivement de su
programa une telle tendance à un livre entier
dans de nombreux cas les réponses des candidats
lors de l'entretien ont soulevé de sérieux
doutes avec ces fonctionnaires coucou
Stella's avoir la source
viens sur mon gilet il  ne la connaît pas s'il vous plaît
allez est honnête il sait dans le
service de la pauvreté en réalité don disco de Conde de
calabaza kima c'est beaucoup de docume
pour le zébu pourrait
- armintie - le bureau de l'avocat du PS wavi
reconnaît l'existence d'un
problème de faux documents mais rejette la faute sur
le gouvernement du Québec et ses exigences strictes en
matière de documents d'accord Becca
sort pour voir le sousaphone
donc le funky que la fête du chemin a fait était dans un
bouquet  donne ça dur et j'ai dit oui
parce que je suis dans des camps opposés, je décrète un
quart d'acre c'est totalement la fausse
documentation plusieurs fonctionnaires à qui nous avons parlé ont
dit qu'ils subissaient des pressions
pour accepter plus de candidats même dans les cas
où il y avait des soupçons de
corruption - tomate  Chiquita Suzy Amis
janaki échapper à la corruption année Candida
rapport d'impédance résistive ou modèle
Romani Casa de las que existe su Québec
habituellement mais ce ne sera pas primo
interprétation lâche cause d'un incendie la
connaissance enrôlée déformer le couvent
par voir excision prescaler corruption
elle savait  Moussaoui avec wait wait voila
dongs un livre avide qui a choqué un
centre-ville montre ces anciens
fonctionnaires disent qu'ils w  On fait pression pour
augmenter son taux d'approbation pour aider à
équilibrer les livres du ministère. Chaque
investisseur immigrant paie 15 000 $ en
frais de traitement avec environ 1900 dossiers
acceptés par an, soit plus de 28 millions de
dollars dans la poche du gouvernement, dit
exactement les programmes avec un extraterrestre somptueux,
ils peuvent également placer votre  pauvre
soeur mes papiers de sortie
Boyka défenseurs publics du 15 a
salami
le ministère de l'immigration du Québec admet
qu'il y a peut-être eu une cible de taux d'acceptation
dans le passé mais ce n'est plus
le cas il dit que son processus de sélection
est efficace et contribue à l'
intégrité du programme  en 2017, le
gouvernement du Québec a fermé son
bureau d'immigration de Hong Kong en raison de compressions budgétaires
Les investisseurs immigrants chinois peuvent toujours être
convoqués pour une entrevue, mais à
Montréal et ces cas sont beaucoup plus
rares selon les données obtenues en vertu de la
liberté d'information le taux de
candidats acceptés sans entrevue
comme augmenté en flèche ces dernières années de 14
pour cent à 75 pe  Récemment, le
ministre de l'Immigration du Québec a refusé notre
demande d'entrevue par courriel. Son
porte-parole a déclaré que le fait que le
processus de sélection soit entièrement basé à Montréal a
permis au ministère d'assurer une plus grande
cohérence dans le traitement des demandes
et d'augmenter le contrôle de la qualité, mais nous avons
parlé à d'anciens fonctionnaires qui croient que
le  le contraire se passe voir Silicon a
accepté la sagesse à Rockefeller pour un jeune
homme qui vit pour fuir enfin
les coffres de sa sœur possible sont accusés Mona
peut couper un livre dépliant
[Musique]
jusqu'où nos consultants en immigration et nos
avocats sont prêts à aller pour vendre le programme québécois d'
immigration des investisseurs nous  poursuivre
notre enquête en caméra cachée à Hong
Kong avec le millionnaire chinois fictif
m.  Chen et son équipe notre prochain
rendez-vous est avec le groupe globe visa
cette société de conseil en immigration basée
à Hong Kong est l'un des meilleurs
recruteurs de millionnaires pour le
programme des investisseurs québécois encore une fois mr.
Chen est avisé de ne pas révéler aux
autorités canadiennes que sa véritable
intention est de s'installer à l'extérieur de la
province de Québec lorsqu'on l'interroge sur l'
origine de sa richesse, notre
millionnaire fictif admet qu'il n'est pas en
règle avec les autorités fiscales chinoises,
dit le consultant à m.  Chen de ne pas
déclarer tous ses avoirs lors de sa demande au
programme québécois elle lui conseille de
transférer les avoirs problématiques à une société
enregistrée aux Iles Vierges Britanniques
un paradis fiscal
[Musique]
ils vont surtout Hawaï on se
tient la main plus haut  conseils
je dirai suppose que je résous s'il est pendu
c'est vrai pour certains gars dit qu'elle ressemble
à mr.  Chen admet également que sa richesse a
des origines douteuses il lui dit qu'il est un
usurier et qu'il exploite un prêteur sur gages le
consultant propose une solution toute faite
pour les cas difficiles la création d'une
seconde identité ok communauté pour s'amuser
kenick tu mets ton temps j'ai  un plus haut
pour s'amuser non seulement qu'ils sont en
désordre quand je saute ceux-ci accrochez-vous
ne vous arrachez pas les cheveux car je ne
pense pas que je ne devienne pas beaucoup paresseux je ne sais pas
pourquoi votre Lyonnaise votre  longtemps c'est
quelque chose que quelqu'un fera pour le
saint ensemble parce que cela se produit
c'est définitivement une suggestion claire de
frauder le système donc ici nous
créons une deuxième ou une troisième identité
afin d'éviter cette fermeture d'informations
qui pourrait très bien cacher tant de choses
tant de choses et vous avez
une image aussi bonne qu'une imagination que je peux je
dois voir ce qui peut être derrière cela
dans une lettre coup les représentants des visas
disent que mr.  chin n'aurait eu
pratiquement aucune chance d'être sélectionné
comme client alors que visa indique que le programme majeur de
citoyenneté caribéenne n'inclut pas de
changement d'identité, mais le
propre site Web de l'entreprise propose hardiment de
fournir des clients et une nouvelle identité à l'
île caribéenne de st.  Kitts et Nevis
[Musique]
la dernière étape de notre
enquête à Hong Kong est au cabinet Harvey Law Group
fondé par l'avocat québécois
chef François Harvey, ils rencontrent Sue Gaeta
qui a des mots rassurants pour m.  chan
quand mr.  chin dit qu'il n'a pas l'intention de
s'installer au Québec le représentant de Harvey Law Group
lui dit que tout ce dont il a besoin est une
adresse résidentielle dans cette province nous
montrons cette séquence de caméra cachée au
propriétaire du cabinet Jean Francois Harvey
alors j'arrête le football ma facture  boxer je parie que
ce piquillo Chianti la valve dessus
aussi il y a du Québec donc c'est un
booster jamais eu de digitalisation à un
commencement c'est le point d'une catacombe
tu sais c'est que rien depuis
encore en péril quand notre
millionnaire fictif dit qu'il ne souhaite pas
déclarer tous ses actifs aux autorités québécoises
la représentante du cabinet d'avocats ne
voit aucun problème
elle aussi suggère d'utiliser les îles des Caraïbes
pour cacher une partie de ses actifs les
cachant ainsi
aux autorités fiscales québécoises et chinoises quant à m.
Les actifs de Chen en Haïti un conseil clair ne les
déclarez même pas
donc c'est un singe à double face ouais je ne suis pas
très pratique à divulguer Je suis désolé
si vous savez que c'est normal nous avons une
petite pince comme ça c'est en fait
vraiment normal
euh ouvert Césars je  pense que cet argent par
genre cinq alors qu'elle tu sais ouais ouais
ce n'est pas je ne suis pas un fonctionnaire des impôts CV
viens ouais
Oh l'absence est un graphique donc c'est c'est
il s'appelle Nevada où le jeu est juste
navasana donc c'était un peu un étang  dans le
Missouri de l'oreille d'une truie, un duo que Zeke a
publié est allé déclarer un
lemme de prêteur sur gages à percussion rassemblant le
cristal ça alors vous avez vraiment vu
venir avant le gala cela a été considéré comme je
passe le milieu du Dakota une position que nous
surveillons circulaire je cœur quel genre de
vache  ou un alchimiste s'oppose à l'hindouisme,
ils vont faire signe à l'élite qui Nando verra
après notre entretien
Sugata a été renvoyé de l'avocat du Harvey Law
Group Atlanta enseigne également le
droit de l'immigration, ils seraient illégaux
ce qui pourrait être trouvé dans ce qui est légal  elle
suggère oui il dit jean-françois
ils pourraient être tenus responsables des propos de ses
employés selon le
code de déontologie du barreau du québec
qui est sous l'autorité du
cabinet d'avocats elle doit respecter les règles et
les règlements les barreaux du québec mais vous
ne peut pas et ne peut certainement pas suggérer une
commission de quelque chose qui ne va pas
comme éviter de divulguer des actifs qui
doivent être divulgués voici les
résultats de notre enquête à Hong Kong
sur les avocats et les consultants que nous avons
contactés tous sauf un a conseillé à notre
millionnaire fictif de mentir sur son
intention  s'installer à l'extérieur du Québec dans
près de la moitié recommandait de ne pas divulguer
d'être des assassins
eh bien nous avons un
programme d'immigration ici qui est défectueux un
programme d'immigration qui a besoin de
sérieuses réparations peut-être que le gouvernement du Québec
aurait dû faire ce que le
gouvernement fédéral a fait en 2014 nous  besoin d'
abolir le programme, donc vous pensez que le
gouvernement du Québec devrait peut-être simplement
débrancher  c'est absolument absolument
il y a trop de gens qui sont trompés
par ce programme quels sont les
avantages économiques réels pour le Québec du
programme d'immigrants investisseurs nous sommes allés
visiter lemmes ou sort un fabricant d'
huile et de condiments à Québec l'
entreprise en croissance achète de nouveaux
équipements des subventions de  le
programme d'immigrants investisseurs finance 5% de la
famille du projet de modernisation qui veut que
la diligence de Victor coupe Anita et arrête
la douleur est de collecter nos chansons principalement
quelles institutions perspicacité fixie une bombe
pourquoi ils connaissent le site Web s'il vous plaît essayez de vous
connecter uniquement télécharger Amanda tant de
Mata Lama  Sophie est l'exemple choisi
par les intermédiaires financiers pour souligner
le succès du programme immigrant investisseur
devant une commission parlementaire
en 2011
à la même table l'un des
économistes les plus réputés du Québec pfft il fait aussi l'éloge
du programme Sedona Rizzuto je vois mon boulot
prêt mec ouais l'outil  est un
visa d'immigrant Kyoto Canada,
alors alimentez le cadet du salon dans un
série d'études PFF un droit que c'est
l'immigration qui rapporte avec
des taux de rendement spectaculaires pour le Québec
qui nous permettent de créer des emplois à faible
coût bref c'est une aubaine voilà comment ça
marche l'immigrant investisseur fait un
prêt sans intérêt de 1,2 million
dollars au gouvernement du Québec qui lui
sont entièrement remboursés après cinq
ans entre-temps, le Québec place
ces fonds pour qu'ils croissent aux taux
du marché les intérêts générés sont redistribués
en partie aux petites et moyennes entreprises québécoises
par l'intermédiaire de l'AFSC petit Québec la
branche d'investissement de la province depuis  l'année
2000 ces entreprises ont reçu 695
millions de dollars mais le programme est aussi
une mine d'or pour les intermédiaires financiers
qui soumettent des dossiers d'immigrants investisseurs
durant la même période le gouvernement
leur a versé 605 millions en
honoraires professionnels presque autant que ce qui a été donné en
subventions à Bob's finalement  a envoyé
des intermédiaires financiers d'urgence,
dont la Banque Nationale, dans le travail qu'ils ont
financé PFF 10 st  études d'
investisseurs immigrants m.  Fattah a décliné notre
demande d'interview
car il dit qu'il n'a pas travaillé
sur ce sujet depuis des années il nous a référé
à l'économiste co-auteur de l'étude
Pierre Emmanuel
Patsy  Je pense que le réalisateur est le bienvenu,
mais lorsque nous avons
examiné de plus près les données, nous avons remarqué quelque chose de
surprenant.
FST smokey Beck ne finance pas plus
de dix pour cent d'un projet, mais les
chiffres publiés dans ses rapports annuels
comptent cent pour cent des emplois.  comme
s'ils avaient été créés ou sauvés par ces
projets, l'impact sur la création d'emplois
apparaît dix fois plus élevé qu'il
ne l'est réellement.
pas ce que l'économiste Pierre Emmanuelle
périgée a été amené à croire certaines galaxies
si elles le calculent de cette façon en
tenant compte de tous les emplois bien sûr ça
gonfle  c'est les chiffres de la création d'emplois mais
c'est ouais ouais c'est pas ce n'est pas la
bonne façon de faire
non Madame Monsieur et selon
Québec vu dissuader général FST enfumé Beck
ne fait pas de suivi pour s'assurer que les emplois
promis ont effectivement été créés qui
soutiennent une place qui  a besoin de personnes dynamiques
désireuses de contribuer à sa
croissance en savoir plus sur le Québec et
son programme d'
immigrants investisseurs  entrer et
ensuite passer par la paperasse donne-nous de l'
argent pour les petites entreprises et ensuite
nous laissons une grande partie de l'impact économique est
perdue et de l'impact social aussi et donc
c'est quelque chose qui signifie vraiment que
je pense qu'aborder le numéro un aussi les
revenus du programme ont disparu  ont
considérablement baissé parce qu'ils dépendent
des taux d'intérêt qui ont atteint des creux historiques au
cours de la dernière décennie pour contrer
cela, le gouvernement  Le gouvernement a récemment augmenté
le montant du prêt que les
investisseurs immigrants doivent fournir, mais selon
Pierre Emmanuel Paradis, cela ne suffira pas. L'
un des défenseurs du programme
estime maintenant qu'une réforme majeure est nécessaire. Le
Canada a beaucoup à offrir.
de qualité société
économie forte pays pacifique et nous avons le
droit de demander une contribution conséquente
en retour obtenons la contribution
que nous méritons et nous aurions
dû nous assurer que nous priorisons les familles
allaient rester au Québec etc la
majorité des millionnaires chinois qui
est entré au Canada en utilisant le
programme d'immigration des investisseurs du Québec s'est installé sur la
côte ouest à Vancouver le programme a
reçu une couverture médiatique négative ici
parce qu'on lui a reproché d'avoir
contribué en partie à la
flambée des prix de l'immobilier Le programme du Québec a
été la plus grande composante de la richesse médiane de l'
émigration  la migration ici à
Vancouver et au Canada et c'est une
énorme composante de ce qui propulse la
propriété pr  Lorsque vous regardez des propriétés
qui valent cinq six millions de
dollars, vous savez que cela n'a rien
à voir avec les revenus locaux, mais avec la
richesse étrangère et les revenus étrangers et une grande
partie de cela est le programme québécois d'
immigration des investisseurs. Ian Young
est basé à Vancouver.  correspondant du
South China Morning Post, un quotidien publié
à Hong Kong, il enquête depuis des années sur
ces migrants millionnaires et sur
le rôle du programme québécois d'immigrants
investisseurs
Je pense que le programme québécois d'immigrants
investisseurs est une arnaque du début à la fin Je
pense que tous ceux qui sont impliqués  dans
le programme sait que vous savez, je pense
que cela inclut les décideurs politiques, les
personnes qui le facilitent et les
immigrants eux-mêmes, je veux dire, ils savent
que cela ne sert pas le but
qu'il est censé servir juste un
exemple.
résidence dans le cadre du
programme québécois lorsqu'elle et sa famille ont
obtenu leur droit d'établissement officiel au Canada en
2006 e  Ils n'ont même pas pris la peine de prendre l'avion pour
Québec, ce que j'ai fait ici est ici à
Vancouver et seulement dix jours après leur
arrivée, ils vous ont quitté
, puis après cela, vous savez que pendant
les six, sept ou huit années suivantes, leur
présence réelle au Canada était alors minime.
Joe Jingly est retourné à Vancouver en
2014 pour que son fils soit éduqué au
Canada, son mari est resté en Chine pour
continuer sa pratique du droit, ce
qu'on appelle communément une famille satellite, elle a
acheté cette propriété de cinq millions de dollars
à West Vancouver, une maison de cinq chambres et sept
toilettes.  pour elle et ses deux fils,
c'est un problème pourquoi garer votre argent sur
le lot de beaucoup de ces
investisseurs importateurs veulent simplement retirer de l'argent
de la Chine qu'ils veulent mettre d'une
manière qui ne soit pas dans un compte bancaire
facilement  traçable, elle a acheté deux
voitures de luxe Vancouver est devenue la
capitale nord-américaine des voitures de luxe en
raison de la demande du marché asiatique des
millionnaires
l'année dernière a dû comparaître en plaisantant devant
l'Immigration  et la Commission du statut de réfugié
parce qu'elle n'a pas vécu au pays
assez longtemps pour renouveler son
statut de résidente permanente, on lui a demandé pourquoi elle
ne s'était pas installée au Québec, comme elle aurait
dû,
elle a parlé à la commission d'une courte visite
à Montréal et que ne connaissant pas le français,
elle  ont été trop difficiles pour elle
de vivre au Québec, elle a mentionné être
entrée dans une station-service en étant consternée que
les gens parlaient français et qu'ils
ne puissent pas communiquer avec elle en anglais
maintenant, vous penseriez que ce serait une
connaissance raisonnablement commune parmi les
gens  que si vous allez déménager au
Québec mais que les gens au Québec parlent en
fait français en 2016 en
plaisantant payé seulement 69 dollars d'
impôt sur le revenu aujourd'hui sa maison vaut près de 8
millions de dollars nous avons essayé de la contacter
plusieurs fois mais elle a refusé notre
demande d'entrevue l'une des choses les plus
ridicules à propos du programme québécois d'
immigrants investisseurs et de la
migration des millionnaires en général est le
peu d'argent que
ces gens déclarent une fois  ils arrivent
ici au Canada et le peu d'impôt sur le revenu
qu'ils paient, ils paient moins d'
impôt sur le revenu dans de nombreux cas et les réfugiés l'
une des principales raisons pour lesquelles le
gouvernement fédéral a supprimé son propre
programme d'investisseurs en immigration en 2014,
les très faibles recettes fiscales
perçues auprès de  ces migrants à la fin
BC et Ontario doivent payer une grande partie de la
facture des dépenses liées à ces
migrants mais sans aucun des
avantages financiers reçus par le Québec
à leur arrivée mur un Québec
prend l'argent c'est c'est
Vancouver qui paie la note  pour
ces coûts annexes comme la gomme, vous connaissez
le coût de l'éducation et de la santé, vous
connaissez les routes et des choses comme ça
ouais Shambala ouais acoustique une fois un grand
Parker dans deux mois dans certaines commandes
déjà
fukiko l'efficacité des soins palliatifs prend en charge un grand
repos de collision
[Musique] la
colombie britannique a pris des mesures pour  essayer de
réduire l'influence des capitaux étrangers
sur le marché immobilier de vancouver
alors que montréal voit un phénomène similaire
un jour, les premiers signes suggèrent que
les spéculateurs immobiliers en Chine continentale
commencent déjà à s'intéresser davantage
au Québec SLAR gist city
[Music]
you